c'è stato un tempo in cui i bambini non
sapevano che cosa giocare
c'è stato un tempo in cui le giornate
erano grigie e noiose
c'è stato un tempo in cui nulla non
l'avevano senso
ma poi
poi l'uomo scondo il pokémon robinho e
pokémon zampino
ed allora l'umanità si salvò
dall'estinzione ore ed ore ed ore ed ore
ed ore ed ore e dora l'esploratrice ore
ed ore di gioco accompagnarono la nostra
infanzia migliaia di pokémon venivano
catturati e migliaia di voi venivano
lanciati quando il pokémon usciva dalla
sfera all'ultimo secondo
ci sto più in pericolo
in cui ci siamo sentiti pezzi e tristi
ma ora quei tempi sono finiti bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenute nessuno video
sono fa vj e oggi siamo su pokémon
rubino omega volevo assolutamente fare
un video su poche ma prima dell'uscita
sento esce tra una settimana quindi
volevo li volevo ringraziare di cuore la
nintendo che mi ha permesso di farlo una
settimana prima la mia infanzia è
saldamente giocare a poker
quindi ho giocato un casinò a pokémon
rubino proprio è stato il mio primissimo
gioco di poker fosse uno dei miei primi
giochi in assoluto tra l'altro dovevo
assolutamente farlo quindi ragazzi è che
posso cominciare dal trono so ragazzi
che diversissimo la tipo di ai tipi di
giochi che faccio di solito però volevo
assolutamente farlo me ne frega niente
tra l'altro gioca pokémon rovino mega in
che io metterei giapponese così tanto
cuore anno perfetto inizia il gioco dai
per partiamo così al di prepotenza
comunque ragazzi fate che sta partendo
da intro bellissima
[Musica]
una goccia una goccia di latte lo voglio
e mio è mio l'ho già preso l'ho già
preso un po che voi qui pronta che lo
sta facendo taxi grazie p non sarei qui
viene il tizio miccichè perfetto è una
cosa bellissima teatro ragazzi si è
visto grado che aveva lo stimolo di
andare al cesso la schermata è una
figata pazzesca
preghiamo start prima che iniziamo più
faccio solo una premessa perché soltanto
lo so che mi chiederete tu vivi come fa
e rovere pokémon prima che esce state
tranquilli vi lascio in descrizione se
volete una demo che se lo possono
provare tutti quanti la demo ovviamente
di pokemon rovino mega zaffiro alfa non
mi fate domande ce l'avete lì basta
siamo partiti ragazzi ciao scusa mento
fatto attendere ciao zio come stai io
sono pct mi chiamo il professor poche ma
io ti chiamo processo al pc questo è un
po questo è il mio pene invece grave poi
facciamo conoscenza ragazzi cos'è affido
io sto guardando un po che figo
raccontami qualcosa di te sei un ragazzo
e una ragazza
ovviamente io sono una ragazza perché
non si vede in faccia su due belle
coppie così ho capito come ti chiami ok
allora mi chiamo era una bellissima
ragazza e mi chiamo ugo diciamo un po
per questa volta perché mi piace il nome
ugo che ha qualche problema allora si
chiami un sì esatto chiama 1 ora che
senso
quindi tu sei un come stai traslocando
ad alba nova la mia città natale
tutto chiaro stiamo traslocando ad alba
nova atleti pronti perché c'è un po che
morì a sinistra perché c'è mary a noi
azzurri quella forza fatti coraggio e
tuffati nel mondo dei pokémon dovetti
attendere i sogni avventure uniche un
sacco di amici e sicuro questa nando da
gesù che in paradiso cos'è ragazzi sta
andando bene
sono morto sei finito qui vi do spero
che vi sia piaciuto da solo sì mi sembra
poi una roba verso uno solo lui bello
comunque fantastico che fa
oddio degli alberi e giosun tomas epico
si può giocare madonna è leggermente
gamba gambling campata cambiata la
grafica da ugo eccomi qui
ma no questa è albanova ti piace se ho
visto degli
per i mai visti questa nostra nuova casa
un'aria un po antiquata ma sembra molto
confortevole non credi c'è anche una
stanza bella tutta per te perfetto
ragazzi c'è una stanza hanno fatto
abbastanza per hugo mamma perché ci sono
degli ormoni nudi in camera tua che cosa
stai facendo cosa ne pensa papà di
questa cosa qui e young oh guarda che
cosa ne dici non è bello qua è
bellissimo soprattutto il deretano di
servizio che è un ma ciò che però credo
ti abbia chiesto conto sono 7.500 euro è
infatti si è incazzata grazie pokemon
traslocata si chiama ma ciò che ho che
oggi va beh ma sì sì ma zia mimi specchi
dove va in palestra che sei un gran figo
ma ciò che o c'è qualcos'altro di
insensato da dire no un gol abbastanza
di sopra vede alla tesoro consiste
tranquilla zia non mi non per le palle
che devo andare in giro a vedere che
cosa c'è in tv c'è un film in tv due
uomini ballano su tasti di un enorme
pianoforte ma è un film per drogati una
bambola gli azzurri il suo dare fa
tornare alla mente dei bei ricordi e
cioè pulito lo sterco del cane fammi
capire si chiama professor bizzo abito
proprio qui di fianco a trovarlo va bene
lasciatemi andare a trovarlo perché ho
paura allora i ragazzi non oso pensare
sta ragazza che va in giro e dice
piacere ugo magari non e riceve la
donzella come ti chiami lei si senta
adesso il fare cerebroleso mi mi dice
dove trovare il professor b e c è il
proprio subito mi chiama sentito fatto
sapere cosa mi stavo per chi lascia il
microfono so cosa non lo è
il professore fuori per una ricerca sul
campo mi dispiace è vero ragazzi mi
stanno tornando i ricordi come non so
cosa avete pazienza ma non posso fatali
le cose nel laboratorio cos'è sta roba
sembra una macchina importante ti fa il
gelato mostra la mappa non aveva un file
gelato perfetto devo capire ancora ma
siccome per la mappa come un gol
denuncia iscritto o ascolta se clicco su
google che cosa mi fa vedere vedere la
alle medaglie perfetto inizia avventura
11 2011 c hai azzeccato in pieno allo
ragazzi stiamo stiamo per assistere al
momento più epico della storia dei
videogame secondo me poi non lo so che
non è prudente avventurarsi oltre se non
è poco tempo la teneva affanculo non hai
capito dal vero 71 stati con chi stai
parlando io sono il grandissimo hugo sta
bene l'erba alta si ascolta zia p platì
l'armata e fammi passare niente
nel nervoso perché di cosa devo andare a
salvare quel deficiente
niente ragazzi non posso perché c'è sta
stronza allora andiamo 41 sbagliato io
devo prima parlare con sta tizia tu devi
essere un azzeccato noi siamo i tunisini
piacere di conoscerti abbiamo un figlio
della tua età ma non pensavo lamenta se
con una ragazza che si chiama google non
vedere che qual è la sua reazione
proprio devo andare alla madonna in
prima persona pure giorno
ciao zio come stai sì sì piacere ugo
sono un break si può a qualche mani
piena forma strumenti alla mano è che
sta facendo
che fai ehi tu chi sei ma innanzitutto
stai calmo che pareva uno schiaffo che
tanti sver gino la faccia vedevo l'ora
di conoscerti ci chiediamo allora
ragazzi sono il grandissimo ugo quindi
tutti tutti mi amano non c'è verso devo
andare mi fa incazzare lui dava mica ti
prendo a calci
ecco bravo hai messo due ore sento delle
urla provenienti dalla joe che si fa che
possiamo fare arrivare tu sei qui ai
file a minchiona io vado lì e faccio
superman super ugo ok ragazzi stiamo per
assistere alla che fa adesso minchia
l'animazione proprio quando era in
pokémon quello vecchio c'era un omino
che correva ha fatto a pixel adesso va
bene il tuo per favore aiutami si ti
aiuto io se non ti preoccupare nella mia
borsa cena poche veloce la possa fare
ragazzi e sto per compiere un atto
eroico ma ma ma ha fatto la pizza ma dai
che scherzo
stavo ha scherzato che doveva ilona
sonics imac i cani innanzitutto perché
tali uno schiaffo curate ascolta fammi
vedere che cosa ha detto io ancora non
ho
questa questa è stata la decisione più
fottutamente difficile della mia
infanzia giuro vediamo che scegli un po
che non la facciamo io scelgo quello che
ho scelto io per la prima volta che era
torci che è cioè io sono sempre stato
pro i pokémon di fuoco non so perché ciò
sta cosa che mi piace i fan di fuoco
quindi scelgo questo mi casa in
combattimento subito così apparso un po
i kin keen king ieri io non ho mai
capito non si pronunciano il nome quindi
forte se galotta cisco abbattere sto
deficiente in qualche modo ci siamo
ragazzi di gela e la mia prima volta
dopo dopo anni se non ci posso credere
ce la faccio ce la faccio daviver acer
braciere di brutto
io vado sulla potenza ma zio chi gioca
col fuoco si scotta lo sai anche tu a
mamma ascoltami è costato cosa tocchi
scatta non è morto e piccoli dicevo è
morto ogni volta che che ammazzava un po
campo in teoria non è che muoiono di
poche ma perché sennò mi sarei rovinato
l'infanzia di brutto sono stato dottori
sorprese mentre ero intento a studiare
pokémon selvaggi perché tu vai vicino al
buco del deretano dei pokémon li guardi
così ma tu sei un sono ugo zio vedi che
mi conoscono tutti perché s'è mai visto
una tipa chiamarsi ugo però mi stupisce
in un casino e comunque è fatto e
rifatto da dio
questo sicuro me ringraziamento per
avermi salvato per tenere il proprio
monte scelto va bene google ice le torce
e già che ci sei perché non dai un
soprannome a torce 3 penserete mica che
io lo tenga così si ha voglia che li
vediamo allora che noi soprannome vuoi
dargli lo chiamiamo bresaola bresaola
perché non è più azzeccato di questo non
poteva uscire di sicuro ragazze se
dovessi perderti usa le navi mappa nei
tumulti poken absis il tranquillo zio
cio tutto devo andare a combattere
contro il controllo al tizio che non mi
brandon come si chiamano mi ricordo si
sia a volermi chiamare che la bambina si
è tolta dalle palle perchè giuro mi
stava dando suina riina maniera
incredibile e da secoli che non gioca un
po che adesso siamo liberi di fare la
minchia che vogliamo
fatemi andare di qua per forza di quadra
se non voglio passare in mezzo ai box
e poi una rialzi devi incazzata ci siamo
anche perché vai bresaola giunge certo
ragazzi brad rosaura avuta usa braciere
vai bresaola george era possibile se ho
vinto anche perché io uso perché io sono
sempre avuto statati causa i pokemon di
fuoco sempre perché il tratto nell'erba
trovi pokémon in genere di tipo erba non
sempre però in genere di pokémon di tipo
fuoco mi sono sempre stati abbastanza
d'aiuto solo che c'hai nel deretano
quando fai la palestra di acqua pro ii
sono un altro paio di mazzeo ragazzi
andiamo avanti che mi se
maledetta la vita no no no no no bravo
bravo baffa lo vedi questo dove ti
guardava il professor beach prima
trovate di mettere però è il presente ma
veramente non è per cattiveria però non
è veramente per cattiveria però mica mi
girano cos'è che vuoi tu
cioè io lavoro in un pokémon market ne
frega un cazzo ma devi andare a
incontrare il mio amico perché sono non
ci arriverò mai
ecco qua diaz e ce l'ho fatta cioè lo fa
non fate domande non so neanch'io come
ok ci siamo anche cazzo sei perché
guardi l'acqua è caduto il telefono
ma perché se guarda che tu sei un così
mi ha detto che sono a si fa parti ha
dato un po che ho già che ci siamo
lottiamo ma ci siamo ragazzi siamo sullo
scontro decisivo epico proprio con
l'iniziale avanti bresaola fantasma
perché la cosa bella di soldi di pokémon
che è stata fantastica e che l'altro
deficiente prende sempre in poche
mochetti padano supera efficace quindi
prende marchi di semi usa un attacco di
acqua e cielo nel deretano quindi ho già
perso praticamente che fa io gli ho
osato gradazione grazie a dio ed
efficiente non si ricorda che può usare
pistola acqua se ce l'ha non credo ce
l'abbia spero non ce l'abbia non usavano
usare un usato azione si se questa
figlia sto sudando freddo ragazzi the
news ha visto la d'acqua cielo nel
didietro magma di brutto proprio mai
così bravo zio bra ancora uno e sei
morto azione grazie a dio mi chiamasse
mi fa brutto colpo sono molto io però ok
bye bye bye sea non lo so se lo vedi ma
anche tutto deve filare tu sai dove
perché è stato bellissimo avvincente
soprattutto non ci sono state delle
volte in cui ho perso contro sto tizio e
quindi avevo paura di fare una figura di
merda ma vabbè lascia che ti rimette in
sesto i sessi poche ma che cazzo sei un
centro pokémon trasformano e tornati in
forze perfetto credo di aver capito
perché mio padre si interessa tanto a te
un go ma di sicuro non è per il nome
amico mio però va bene non è da poco con
testi e già affezionato mica l'ho
chiamato presa aula figurati sono una
pensionata è ora di tornare al
laboratorio forniamo insieme uno va bene
così write e stato bellissimo ma posso
centrale nella palestra si posso già
batterla 6 serie hanno nominato oggi al
centro pokémon questo pensavo fosse un
apparecchio o meno dai ma sono sotto
effetto di droghe o cosa buon compleanno
ugo tanti auguri e il mio compleanno
davvero grazie grazie davvero
mimì regali il centro pokémon tutto
quanto la partoriente buon compleanno ti
augura un anno ricco di felicità
veramente io compro negli anni tra 5 6
mesi pro grazie concludo qua ragazzi
perché me ne mettiamoci dentro al centro
perché noi siamo belli per festante un
bellissimo ragazzi doveva assoluta
dovevo assolutamente fare l'inizio
perché è un momento che ho vissuto io da
piccolo la mia infanzia con pokémon
rubino il primo ripeto una trota siccome
so già che tutti vi chiederete fa
poi giocherà poche non prima che sia
uscito mi lascio la demo in descrizione
potete scaricarlo tutti così non mi la
demo così almeno non era limitato a
stati di domanda è siamo a poi aggiungo
anche una cosa epica volevo fare una
specie di contest forse cosa ragazze chi
si scarica la demo di pokémon nella
descrizione e mi fa una fan art sul tema
pokémon dove ci sono anch'io
quella che mi piace di più la vetta come
parte della settimana quindi la più
bella ad altri 100 che l'hanno fatta
chiese che se l'avranno fatta bene mando
una maglietta mia firmata di pokémon
firmata da me così almeno facciamo una
roba tipo contest carino quindi ragazzi
è stato bellissimo giocare un'altra
volta dopo che ho preso rubino perché
migliaia di masto nel cuore proprio sono
ancora troppo contento di averlo fatto
comunque ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto come
al solito lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a pacciani facebook e come una
livida tratta descrizione se volessi di
chieti riuscivi a 1 prossimo vito belle
ragazze
[Musica]